developing tonight we are learning more
about the SUV that crashed into a home
in northwest Las Vegas 8 news now
reporter Brian will is live at the scene
joining us with the very latest
information and Brian what have you
found out
good evening Brian yeah right here is
where that happened at the house behind
me here on the 7200 block of Chesterton
Drive which is near Tanea way and Smoke
Ranch Road it happened around 4 this
afternoon and Witnesses tell me the
person at home at the time is in
complete shock
our mom came in running saying that
there's a car inside a house Brenda
Gomez's mom was the first to point out
to them what happened to their
neighbor's house an SUV slamming into
the side of the home she had just got
home from work okay so as soon as she
was pulling in she heard the the sound
right behind her so she was confused
because she was still outside didn't see
anything until she saw people pointing
towards the house and she walked over to
see what happened right after the
Collision they rushed over to find the
renter of the home in a state of
disbelief she doesn't shock she she
didn't understand what was going on she
was just
uh describing what she saw she was
describing what happened and she she
wasn't okay Gomez says the woman inside
the home was in the kitchen cooking at
the time of the crash and she feared for
the lives of those in the vehicle she
was cooking at the time so she had to
run back inside to turn it off but they
were just shocked at because they can
see the people inside the car so they
were just very worried for them
tonight as you can see that SUV has been
removed from that home and it is boarded
up tonight as for the condition that
people in the SUV the driver and the
passenger do remain in the hospital
tonight in critical condition as we know
right now there was one person at home
at the time of it and that woman and she
was just too shaken to speak to us as
you can imagine reporting live in the
Northwest Valley Brian will 8 News Now